j'ai une idée par contre avec vous
faites ce que vous voulez toujours très
bon j'ai ça va être bon et beau le
monsieur au sénat après tout le monde
est beau comment débat où il fermait les
yeux fermés les yeux et dormait dans
cette position maintenant je vais
changer de personnalité
je vais changer sa personnalité l'accord
gilles vous êtes cyril hanouna et vous
vous prenez le contrôle du plateau 1 2 3
vous avez bien vous faire chier qu'est
ce qu'il ya qu'est ce qui se passe à
telle at war vas-y fais ta chronique
ok lapentti chronique bien sûr et j'aime
la chronique et bas cet aprem je sais
pas si ça vous intéresse ou pas non non
non je fais quoi du coup est votre eau
ni mais arrêtez de tout c'est comme ça
non cet aprem on est allé dans les rues
de paris demandent au public ce qu'il
pensait de benjamin voulais qu'on voie
ça pas oui madame ah oui benjamin
castaldi et benjamin castaldi allez on
enseigne
brigitte et leur il est quoi c'est pas
d'oreillettes et laurie n'est pas pro
voulait lancer à tort 48
oui on danse on danse c'est plus
physique je faisais régie comme ça c'est
la merde
la chronique la chronique on est en
retard la chronique ghazi non mais ça va
donner mais je vais m'asseoir je vais
aller à l'essai on le laisse enfin le
court lui allait alors est ce que vous
voulez dire que messmer et ton spectacle
vous l'avez dit soba messmer messmer
mais ce père en spectacle bientôt sur
tf1 vendredi soir rue star sous hypnose
c'est mon émission préférée
j'adore cette émission franchement même
arthur là dedans je trouve sympathique
c'est une super émission c'est génial
bravo messmer j'adore ce que tu veux on
sait oslo disent manquer
les petits contrer les petits beauté on
y va la castaldi son livre je n'ai pas
lu mettra son ca
tiens devant lui
il combat est le combat au bal en bal
est aussi celle où ça va oui très bien
ça va et vient fermer les yeux et
maintenant à mon signal de les remonter
aux consciences d'aller vous souvenir de
tout dans les moindres détails et avec
le 1e dre chez vous avec le 2 le sourire
montre à votre visage
le bien-être remonte aussi et avec le 3
complètement libérée de toute suggestion
et je pense qu'on peut applaudir gimeno
merci
quelques retards je sais pas ce que je
fais là qu'est-ce que je fais là rld
avait pris possession du plateau vous
êtes ici j'étais bon